So last night was the second night of the
Democratic National Convention, we had a live
stream for the full two hours.
There was the sort of formal nomination process
of Joe Biden with each state casting their
delegates proportionally or 100 percent for
different candidates.
And it was a significantly better night.
The night won, without question.
There were fewer of these energy sucking moments
were after like an okay speech.
They would cut to low energy, smooth jazz
or something like that.
It was better put together.
There were actually some very interesting
moments headlined by Joe Biden's wife, Dr.
Jill Biden, who did the last speech of the
night, who I realized in watching her she
would be a better president than Donald Trump.
Forget about Joe Biden for a moment.
I was trying to think, is there any issue
where if you said, David, we need either Donald
Trump or Jill Biden to figure out this issue,
is there any issue or I would pick Donald
Trump and there really isn't.
I mean, even on Corona virus, quite frankly,
it's hard to imagine anyone doing a worse
job than drunk Trump on the virus.
But as a doctor of education, Jill Biden would
just understand.
Oh, it's a medical situation.
Oh, well, we need to let doctors take the
lead rather than than Donald Trump, for example.
But I'm heading at getting ahead of myself
a little bit here.
One of the best moments was one of the best
lines of the night, really was former Secretary
of State John Kerry referring to Donald Trump's
overseas trips as blooper reels.
Take a look at this.
Donald Trump inherited a growing economy and
a more peaceful world.
And like everything else he inherited, he
bankrupted it.
When this president goes overseas, it isn't
a goodwill mission.
It's a blooper reel.
He breaks up with our allies and writes love
letters to dictators.
America deserves a president who is looked
up to not laugh.
That that actually made me laugh in the moment.
And John Kerry was was quite good at laying
out the importance of voting for Joe Biden
and to remove Donald Trump in November.
Bill Clinton also spoke and it was fine.
There was debate about whether Bill Clinton
should speak or maybe instead it should be
Al Gore who is sort of a direct testament
to what happens when not enough people vote
and you end up winning the popular vote, losing
the Electoral College and changing the course
of history.
Maybe Al Gore should have spoken instead.
Maybe Al Gore should or should have spoken
in addition to Bill Clinton.
We heard from Congresswoman Alexandria Cosio
Cortez in a much anticipated speech.
It was very short.
She formally nominated Bernie Sanders to be
the nominee.
There were some people who said, oh, it's
a snub.
It was really a formality.
Bernie was set to receive delegates from some
states, so someone has to nominate him.
It was not a snub.
It was rather procedural.
And NBC News took some heat because they misreported
what Alexandria, Cosio, Cortez did and they
made a big deal out of it.
I'm not going to since it really wasn't a
big deal and I don't want to play into that.
But we did hear from AOC and then.
Yeah.
Dr. Jill Biden, let's take a look at just
a little bit of her speech and you'll see
this is the wrap up and you'll see Joe Biden
come out and embrace her.
If you're watching and you'll hear him say
just a few words if you are listening.
I know that if we entrust this nation to Joe,
he will do for your family what he did for
ours, bring us together and make us whole
carry us forward in our time of need.
Keep the promise of America for all of us.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Joe Barton.
Salzman has heard, you know.
Excuse me, you can see why she's the love
of my life, the rock of our family.
She never gives herself much credit.
But the truth is, she's the strongest person
I know.
She's a backbone, like a ramrod.
She loves fiercely, cares deeply.
Nothing stops her when she sets her mind and
getting something right.
So, yeah, I mean, it's all pretty cheesy.
This this isn't the type of packaging that
appeals to me.
This isn't the type of political event that
But it doesn't matter.
I'm not the target here.
And realistically, neither are you.
Realistically, anybody who is watching the
David Pakman show on YouTube listens to political
podcasts.
If you listen to the podcast.
You're not the target.
You've already decided.
Right.
And so I think it's important for us to keep
that in mind.
But I have to say, when you hear about and
learn about the tragedy of Joe Biden's life,
losing his first wife and child in a car accident,
and then you hear about Jill Biden becoming
a mother to Joe Biden's two sons while she
was in graduate school, you just see the way
the Bidens relate to each other.
It is a reminder because of the stark contrast
that's in the White House right now about
how absurd the Trump administration and Trump
as president is.
On a personal level, Malana seems to hate
Trump.
Some of Trump's kids seem to hate him.
Trump seems to think some of his kids are
idiots, like none.
None of this is normal.
And obviously we can separate.
You know, if their politics are great, who
cares about their home lives in this particular
case with Donald Trump?
It's all related and it's all very, very bad.
The same delusions of grandeur and narcissism
that make his personal life and family life
a disaster, make his administration a disaster.
And that was you know, I didn't really need
the convention because the choices are so
crystal clear for me this time around.
But I do think that this second night, particularly
with Dr. Jill Biden and some of the backstory
on Joe Biden's life, I do think it actually
was far better put together the night, number
one.
So tonight we're going to be hearing from
Senator Elizabeth Warren, which I'm very much
looking forward to.
Again, as someone who competed against Joe
Biden in the Democratic primary this year.
We heard from by Bernie on Monday night making
the case that if you supported Bernie in 2016,
if you supported Bernie in 2020.
Here is why it is so important to vote for
Joe Biden in November.
I'm interested to see how Elizabeth Warren
puts together a sort of similar argument.
I'm not as much looking forward to hearing
from Nancy Pelosi and Hillary Clinton tonight,
although I think it will be interesting to
see what approach they take and whether they
play to the left or they play to the middle
or what they do.
We're going to hear from former Congresswoman
Grap Gabby Giffords, who is a tragically was
a victim of gun violence years ago and also
headlining tonight.
We will hear from vice presidential candidate
Kamala Harris.
And we're also going to hear form from former
President Barack Obama.
All leading up to the final night tomorrow
when we will hear from the nominee himself,
Joe Biden.
And it's much anticipated for different reasons
by different people.
The right is anticipating Joe Biden's speech
with the idea that he's going to be a barely
coherent and unable to put together anything
sensible or so or sensical, whereas I'm interested
in seeing what is the approach in order to
bring people in.
In other words, centrists, center left, disaffected
Republicans, progressive leftists, former
Berney people, so on and so forth.
So I will see you tonight at eight, 45 p.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube, twitch and or Facebook
your preference for the start of night three.
And we will be back, of course, tomorrow with
analysis and preparation for the final night
of the Democratic National Convention.
And then we have to get ready for the Republican
National Convention happening next week.